[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday july 14th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
as crypto prices have plunged and
questions have been raised about the
viability of some crypto lenders and
brokers
another kind of company connected to the
crypto space has been hurt
web 3 businesses that offer their own
digital tokens
investors poured four and a half billion
dollars into blockchain-based companies
last year according to crunchbase
but games like axi infinity where
players earn assets like virtual pets
they can sell or blockchain based
fitness apps like step in where users
earn tokens based on how much they jog
have seen the value of their digital
assets crash
it raises the question if investors see
less value in bitcoin and other digital
currencies how much is a token one in a
video game worth
joining us to discuss how these startups
are coping and what it means for the
development of web 3 is our startups and
venture capital reporter berber gin
hi berber thanks for coming on the show
hi zoe very excited to be here
so let's start with the investors who
poured so much money into this over the
last year or so
how are they reacting to these companies
now that we're seeing declines in crypto
values yeah that's a great question i
think
last year
because there was so much enthusiasm
amongst just normal people
for these games what happened was that a
lot of the prices of crypto tokens went
up and so users piled into the games
they wanted to play
but they didn't necessarily use these
web three
services because they really liked in
actually infinity's case the game itself
it's because they wanted to make money
so what's happening now is as the crypto
market crashes people are sort of
fleeing from a lot of these
projects that were built on the
blockchain
and as a result investors are in a
really tricky situation last year they
sort of bought into a lot of the hype
around these startups and failed to
distinguish between companies that
actually had products that people wanted
to use
and companies that offered services that
people used because they could speculate
on assets and make a lot of money so a
lot of investors now i think are
rethinking their strategy for investing
in the space
and what they're having trouble
discerning is how much of the crypto
market actually
can offer users a better alternative to
existing social media networks games
that are already on the internet and
which types of companies are fueled
mostly by speculation of these digital
tokens which drove up the valuations and
the prices venture capitalists are
willing to pay for companies last year
right so what's the hype and and what's
i guess you know the real secret sauce
seems to be what they're figuring out so
how are the companies then addressing
that how are they trying to say we're
the real deal
yeah so that's an interesting question i
mean with axiomfinity
the company realized that
they were having trouble striking a
balance between users who wanted to play
the game and
a larger cohort of users who were
playing the game to make money
and so what they've done is actually
they're going to roll out a new version
of the game that doesn't require users
to actually own cryptocurrency assets
i think that is a really clear
indication that a lot of these so-called
web3 startups are still figuring out
whether they can
you know attract users and offer a
product that they want beyond the sort
of incentives that come with being able
to make a quick buck off some of these
tokens that
the startups issue so i think a lot of
these sort of web 3 startups that
issue digital tokens on the blockchain
to try and acquire users are in this
tougher spot now of
you know having to develop products that
people will feel attached to beyond the
money that they can make from playing
those games
how are crypto skeptics reacting to this
are they just jumping for joy and saying
i told you so
i think so i think last year because
there was so much money and hype pouring
into the space you know vcs were like
changing their twitter handles to like
nfts and adding ethereum addresses to
their usernames
last year that sort of environment made
vcs who were skeptical of crypto sort of
more hesitant to speak out
now given the crypto crash and the
general slowdown in vc investing
a lot more
vcs traditional vcs that aren't sort of
all in on crypto have been
more open about their reservations about
the space and it's definitely created
uh bifurcation within silicon valley
there are a set of vcs that are
extremely
bullish on crypto there are a set of vcs
that
you know don't want to touch it at all a
lot of them are also just investing in
sort of
safer crypto companies like
infrastructure type startups that
help other services build on the
blockchain or crypto exchanges that
facilitate trading but actually very few
vcs i think are pouring money into like
the actual projects
that are trying to supplant some of the
traditional consumer internet services
that's the sort of founding block or the
reason why crypto's supposedly so
useful in the first place but actually
not a lot of vcs have put money into
those companies
so does the the crypto rut that and some
of these vcs pulling their money away
from digital tokens spell the end of web
3.
so one way to look at this is just
from the amount of capital that's been
raised dedicated to crypto investing
i'm thinking of you know three of the
largest crypto specific funds andreessen
horowitz paradigm and han ventures
they have over eight billion dollars
dedicated to crypto investing
so from that perspective funding for
crypto startups and web 3 startups will
continue it'll probably be
a lot slower than it was last year
and there is an open question of whether
there is actually a big enough market
to
invest all that capital so if you're a
crypto skeptic who thinks that
much of the industry is fueled by you
know retail traders who
like speculating on risky assets you
might believe that this sort of spells
the beginning of the end for crypto
projects but
just by the virtue of the amount of
capital that's been reserved to help
fund and get these projects off the
ground
we're going to see more crypto and web 3
companies getting funded in the coming
years
all right that's our reporter berber gin
thanks so much for joining us berber
thank you very much
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you